dans cette petite camionnette six jeunes
âgés de 17 à 22 ans avait pris place
leur objectif se rendre en discothèque
originaire du rhône ils empruntaient
l'autoroute a6 m'est arrivé à hauteur de
crêches sur saône
le conducteur perd le contrôle on sait
juste qu'il s'agit d'un seul véhicule
qui a été
frappez les glissières de sécurité qui
s'est retrouvé sur le flanc pour
l'instant les causes ne sont pas encore
déterminées l'enquète y travaillent
sitôt l'alerté donnée très rapidement de
nombreux moyens de secours ont convergé
vers les lieux de l'accident
à leur arrivée les pompiers déplore un
mort un blessé en urgence absolue de
blessés légers et de zend n est plus
aucune victime n'était dans la
camionnette
elles étaient trois éjecté 2 qui était
le côté des glissières de sécurité et la
personne décédée qui est sur la voie
rapide
non on n'a rien pu faire si le bilan est
si lourd c'est certainement parce que le
véhicule n'était pas prévu pour
transporter six personnes dans des
conditions de sécurité optimales à
l'arrière nous n'avons pas vu de siège
ou de ceinture de sécurité
trois jeunes voyagent et donc au milieu
d'outillage et de pots de peinture au
moment des tonneaux tous ces objets ne
leur ont laissé que peu de chance les
gendarmes enquêtent d'ailleurs pour
savoir si légalement six personnes
pouvaient être transportées dans cet
utilitaire